before the raptors opening playoff game
last night jessie reyes sang
both national anthems on top of the cn
tower she knelt on the edge walk the
entire time
as she sang both anthems and showed her
brianna taylor mass before she started
singing the u.s anthem
[Music]
oh say can you see
by the dawn's
leaving
[Music]
hearts
[Applause]
looks beautiful looks
people were really divided about this
yeah what did you think of her doing
this
like one the kneeling and then one the
brianna taylor thing
well one it's an iconic moment in her
career
and this is a human rights era we are
allowed to have opinions she made a huge
statement she is an artist she can do
whatever she wants with her artistry
this is a performance and she used it to
say something and this is the time where
we're seeing sports
saying something it was an incredible
way to kick off
kick off the raptors and police
brutality is a global issue
it's not just an american one and our
military fought for our freedom to be
able to respectfully kneel
so i don't think that she did anything
disrespectful in kneeling for both
anthems i thought it was a huge
statement and one that was needed
because she does have a huge platform
wearing the brianna taylor mask
touched me players are wearing their
jerseys with sentiments on it the things
that they're passionate about why can't
she
she was asked to do this they knew very
well
that she was going to do this obviously
they put this together this is a
production
you know i'm not sure if that is even a
live performance to me
from just an audio person that looks
like something that she recorded
and then they got the track of the audio
of the outside and they
they matched it together when you start
producing on that level
you have a cameraman you're going on the
edge walk i mean there's a lot of
factors this was something that she
put together and she wanted to do and
everybody that
was involved in it knew exactly what the
intention was
so obviously the higher-ups didn't see
an issue with it i get that people
want to watch sports and they don't want
to think about
human rights i understand that that's a
thing you want to escape the world and
watching sports
but you wouldn't have the opportunity
to watch sports if people didn't care
about your life
so human rights is a priority issue and
kudos to her for using her platform in
this way i don't know why
anybody would be upset yeah it
definitely wasn't live because the game
was at like
i think it was at 2 p.m yesterday so
that was either yeah either i was trying
to tell if it was sunrise or sunset but
it was one of those
times yeah i mean i mean the performance
isn't live like the time that she did it
but i mean the recording of it her
oh sorry it doesn't literally does not
matter it literally does not matter it
was great
yeah jim says outstanding performance
breathtaking accuses she did really good
to be honest put so much heart and soul
um into it at says it's powerful um
yeah before me says she has a great uh
voice yeah i thought it was
uh q says very powerful and beautiful uh
chelsea's great voice good for her
making her opinion on brianna taylor
known
yeah and i think what you just said like
i mean it might be more
kind of shocking or taking back if the
nba wasn't doing this in general but
yeah all the players are kneeling
there's a few acceptance sections that
aren't kneeling but in general yeah
they're all kneeling during the national
anthem
they're all wearing black lives matter
t-shirts i did find it interesting that
um i don't know if uh jessie lives in
the states but she is kate and i found
it interesting that she did that for
a briana taylor i thought that was
really powerful as a canadian to
to do that yeah it was beautiful so yeah
i know people have a problem with
languages that people have a problem
with but i'm sorry like that's
that's people's freedom they're allowed
to they're allowed to do this
and yeah it's it's definitely important
thing to do and still we're probably at
what we're probably 100 and probably 60
days now
and with no arrests for breanna taylor's
none murder so
so yeah people still need to keep on
doing this we still need to be speaking
out about it and using whatever platform
that we have
to still because it still blows my mind
that still has nothing
nothing has happened with that case so
yeah people need to start
need to keep speaking out